François miteran Nicolas sarci bonsoir
vous vous êtes du RPR et vous êtes
plutôt favorable au oui donc François
mitteran vous a pas convaincu ce soir
même question a-t-il eu raison de se
livrer à cet exercice moi je suis pas
plutôt favorable je suis tout à fait
favorable oui et ce qui m'a convaincu
écoutez je vais vous dire très
franchement j'attendais avec un peu de
crainte cette démission parce que je me
disais que plus les dirigeants
socialistes et le premier d'entre eux
François mitteran s'expriment plus c'est
difficile pour nous tant les fr ont
envie de manifester leur rejet du
socialisme et non pas leur adhésion à
l'Europe on attendait cette émission il
y a eu un très grand battage médiatique
on nous a annoncé c'était le grand
moment de la campagne en fait quoi on a
eu émission plutôt sympathique avec un
président comment pourrais-je dire qui
m'a semblé manquer un petit peu de
souffle en vérité je crois vraiment que
pour tirer l'Europe de l'ornière où elle
se trouve pour sauver l'idée européenne
à laquelle nous croyons profondément
bien on a bien besoin que nous autres
les dirigeants de nos positions on se
retrousse les manches pour expliquer aux
Français que le débat qui est en jeu
c'est un débat essentiel Nicolas Sarko
est-ce que tout même l'ambiguité qu' a
laissé planer ce soir le président de la
République ne vous gêne pas puisque
finalement François mittiran n'a pas
clairement répondu à la question à
savoir quelle serait son attitude si le
nom l'emportait ch leer quand confusion
quand tu nous tiens mais est-ce que ça
vous étonne vraiment que François
Mitterant entretienne la confusion voici
un homme le président République et avec
le respect que je dois la fonction qui
n'a fait que cela tout au long de sa
carrière politique maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il va faire il entretient l'ambiguïté
il avait dit le contraire il y a une
semaine il y a une semaine qu'est-ce
qu'il dit en aucun cas je ne partirai au
début de l'émission qu'est-ce qu'il dit
ce n'est pas un picide donc je ne
partirai pas et au milieu de l'émission
tout d'un coup il dit ah mais il y a
peut-être des arguments ma conviction
elle est faite depuis longtemps François
mitteran n'est pas le général de Gaulle
il ne partira pas si vous me demandez ce
que je le regrette ah certes je le
regrette le plusutôt on sera débarrassé
en quelque sorte des socialiste le mieux
ça sera mais en l'occurrence je ne
souhaite pas que l'Europe soit la
victime du rejet des socialistes dans ce
pays ce doute ne va pas changer la
nature de la fin de la campagne
électorale ENF je je je l'espère et
d'ailleurs je voudrais faire une
remarque moi je suis très attaché à la
procédure référendaire je crois que
c'est très important et je ne regrette
pas le référendum je ne suis pas de ceux
qui disent ah mais les Français y ont un
doute il faut regretter le référendum et
je dis à ceux de mes amis qui sont
partisans comme moi de la procédure
référendaire qu'il fassent attention car
à vouloir transformer les référendums en
plébiscite on aboutira au résultat
invers c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y aura plus
jamais de référendum donc je souhaite
vraiment que dans cette campagne on
reste sur la question qui est posée oui
ou non la France doit-elle continuer à
poursuivre le processus de construction
européenne je souhaite qu'elle réponde
oui merci Nicolas Sar